this machine is spraying pesticides on
rape feed although fast and effective
for plant growth the chemicals are
extremely hazardous to health this
French farmer is now suffering from
cancer due to the use of pesticides on
his farm pesticides are found everywhere
in fruits and vegetables and according
to reports even in babies nappies em EPS
want to promote and accelerate the use
of biological pesticides instead we use
too much of ordinary commercial
pesticides which are chemical which are
mostly dangerous these chemicals were
were designed to kill living subjects
and they are they are causing damage on
our health as well today only seven
biopesticides have received official
certification but getting EU market
approval takes time and biopesticides
are often refused because they are less
effective than their chemical
counterpart any PS want to simplify and
speed up the approval process the range
area of South on organ is Manasa from vm
vegetarian nematode on the mission de
ningun somalis an occurrence of armed of
lavender is nick no lung be honest for I
Messiah some farmers have already
embarked on alternative techniques
without pesticides but this takes more
time and effort biopesticides could be
the solution